hey guys now most of you might not know
this but I used to drink a lot of
alcohol when it was younger and I mean a
lot
but then something huge happened in my
life and I stopped explains you a little
bit later on in the video what exactly
happened but there were five surprising
things that happened when I stopped
drinking alcohol and it changed my life
and that's what I want to share with you
in this so this so what exactly happened
when I stopped drinking alcohol well the
first thing that I noticed was that my
skin looked a lot better just within the
first few days when I stopped drinking
alcohol it was looking clear and
hydrated and just I just looked fresh
especially around my nose area in my
cheeks now alcohol lowers the buttocks
production of an antidiuretic hormone
which helps the body reabsorb water I
also started to think more clearly about
everything you know when you drink
alcohol it it makes you stupid and silly
and you don't even realize it because
you're just so used to it but when I
stopped drinking alcohol I started to
get more clarity on my own life and
where it was headed so my mind felt
refreshed and it was more focused every
single day now it's interesting to know
that alcohol dependence can make it
harder for you to think clearly and also
to remember things and more than that it
can also make it more harder for you to
read other people's emotions and that
takes us to the next point when I quit
alcohol my relationships with other
people also improved why because my mind
was clear and I can also read other
people's emotions I love that now
usually when you drink a lot like I did
you're more self-absorbed you're more
selfish and you focus a lot more
yourself and other people now for some
guys it gets worse
they start to drink at home and they
down a lot of drinks but be careful
because when this happens it can very
quickly turn into an addiction I mean
this happens it can control your whole
life asleep I started to have good
quality sleep at night and in a morning
when I woke up I had energy and I was
ready for the day compared to hangover
don't have energy don't feel like really
doing anything just being useless no I
had energy and it helped me to be a lot
more productive in the day to work
towards my goals a recent study in the
journal alkyl ism clinical and
experimental research found that
drinking before bed increases alpha wave
patterns in the brain which usually
happens when you're awake
but resting so it means you think that
you're sleeping but you're not really
resting and that's why you're still
tired when you wake up in the morning I
save a lot more money you know it's kind
of funny because when you drink a lot
you usually don't have money right but
when that time comes when you need to
buy alcohol suddenly you just have money
and that's why you don't have money for
anything else I just imagine how much
money you will have if you stop drinking
alcohol I mean I still drink I still
have a wine or two while I have dinner
with my wife but I never get drunk and
you know when you're young might think
it's cool to be drunk you have group
pressure but unfold for that trap it's
not cool to look wasted and dumb
alcohol kills people and it destroys
families 30% of all the people who died
in car accidents are caused by drunk
drivers
according to American addiction centers
60 to 70 percent of married couples who
get into physical arguments abuse
alcohol now I want to challenge to stop
drinking alcohol
I mean to the extent where you get drunk
all the time what will it take I heard
this story from a guy once he said he
was watching TV his little daughter came
stood in front of the TV and he got
upset he said why are you doing this and
she said because that I don't want you
to see the beer commercials on TV and
start drinking again and get drunk he
was shocked but he changed his life he
stopped drinking that day what will it
take you to stop drinking alcohol why
did I stop drinking alcohol you know I
lost my brother in my early 20s my
second brother died his car collided
with a big truck he didn't make it and I
started to see life very differently
compared to how I used to how I was
living and wasting my life and I stopped
I became a reborn Christian and I'm not
gonna talk about that on this video but
if you do want to check it out you can
check it out on my second channel that
I'll link for you down here and I'll see
you there
cheers guys
you